alors moi j'ai 23 ans 23 ans que je me
présente comme l'exposé tamis de yasmine
b d'accord également comme entre
guillemets le porte-parole de nombreuses
victimes d'accord je me raconte comment
je les rencontre et comment ça s'est
passé alors vous la rencontrez comment
alors moi j'ai rencontré yasmine déjà à
l'anniversaire de mon ami par le biais
d'une copine qui voulait ramener une
copine d'accord et on a tout de suite
flirter ensemble on a été gentils très
joli très intelligent dire qu'on est
gentil mais ça fleure non mais c'est
très joli mais sinon lorsqu'à la coupure
pour dire que le lieu un match tout de
suite comme à flirter ensemble ne rester
ensemble et les jours devant la laverie
la soirée direct vous êtes à soigner
vous ne pensez pas que le couple
directement mais là il y avait une
attirance on s'est mis en couple très
rapidement au bout de trois quatre jours
quoi d'accord et donc là j'étais
vraiment cool je suis très vite vous
vous sentez qu'il ya en fait présente à
moi comme une infirmière militaire voilà
me parler de son métier etc
c'est vrai que j'avais beaucoup de doute
parce que woods dans ces trois quatre
jours je la voyais faire des achats
compulsifs d'articles de luxe mais je
vérifier pas un si elles payaient
vraiment mais j'ai acheté plein de plein
de choses payer des billets d'avion à
ses copines plein de goodies et non
qualité quoi infirmière militaire
affirme un militaire mais elle acheté
beaucoup d'autres voilà jeté beaucoup de
choses mais je me suis dit mais je fais
tu réellement en mai et me disait
qu'elle avait que sa famille du côté de
son père
détoner une entreprise dans l'armement
une autre là comme une grosse entreprise
quoi donc à vous avez dit elle vous a
dit que sa famille était riche qui a été
extrêmement rugueux alors voilà au bout
de trois quatre jours je commence à
avoir des doutes elle me dit samedi
voilà je ne voulais pas le dire au début
mai mais ma famille est très riche et
c'est pour ça que tu me vois faire des
achats un peu compulsif de ce qui
explique expliquerait finalement bien
sûr donc vous vous dites bon bah ça je
me doute de rien parce qu'en vrai voilà
je m'attends pas être escroqué entre
guillemets chopard arich je suis
quelqu'un comme tout le monde et bien
sûr alors donc sacha ensuite
est-ce qu'elle pourrait cesser combien
de temps lesquels alors je restais au
total un mois et demi avec m à moi nuit
mais c'est quand même beaucoup on
restait beaucoup ensemble - elle
habitait battre avec man je le fais
confiance et elle est venue habiter chez
ma mère qui l'a acceptée oui d'accord
d'accord
elle a eu à sa disposition
de très nombreuses cartes bleues c'est
ça ce que vous voyez oui alors ça pour
le coup ça j'ai vraiment toute
l'histoire de l'escroquerie je l'aï
vraiment découvert à la fin maintenant
que pendant notre relation j'avais
beaucoup de doutes mais c'étaient des
doutes qui était enfin par exemple
j'avais des doutes sur le fait qu'elle
est même très ambitieuse avoir beaucoup
de projets et je la voyais pas faire
grand-chose merkel rester bas j'allais
pas fait elle allait beaucoup chez moi
restait beaucoup chez moi ce méta acsta
est en fait elle a toujours un alibi par
rapport à ça parce que c'est vrai que
moi je faisais part de mes doutes mais
je peux tu me dis que tu as beaucoup de
projets mais je te vois pas faire grand
chose c'est pas méchant mais c'est bien
sûr étiez vous étiez amoureux d'elle ah
oui on aurait vraiment eu un très gros
creux choix coup de foudre tout coup de
foudre vous vouliez voilà que ça ça dure
vous ces dix là je suis trouvé quelqu'un
avec qui j'ai faire un faire une
histoire quoi voilà monsieur
laisser-aller pas d'accord je la croyais
finalement je la croyais tout le temps
est allé beaucoup de technique pour me
faire croire en ses propos entre
guillemets par exemple quand je le
disais quand je faisais part de mes
doutes à me disais je t'avoue ma mère en
fait elle est très malade elle s'est
fait rapatrier elle à l'hôpital de
bordeaux c'est pour ça que tu me vois
pas faire grand chose en ce moment et en
fait c'était toujours quelque chose où
je pouvais pas réagir parce que si je
réagissais vise des bas alors c'est
peut-être vrai ce qu'elle dit et dans ce
cas là je vais le laisser tranquille
peut-être que c'est juste une phase et
que j'ai rien à dire sur ça je veux la
soutenir carrément j'avais beaucoup de
compassion bien sûr alors donc
elle va donc il dit que vous avez vous
avez vous rencontré un s'offrir un point
alors je vais rencontrer au téléphone
d'accord c'est quoi leur ai dit qu'elle
avait un frère mais en fait il n'est pas
beau mais en fait elle même parler de sa
famille qui habitait à paris mais moi je
parle régulièrement avec sa tante
par message d'accord il s'avère en fait
que c'est son autre numéro donc
beaucoup de manipulations comme ça a
parfois j'étais avec elle dans la même
pièce est un extrait des messages avec
le téléphone de sa tante ce qu'elle
avait beaucoup de
genres que sa tante ou des crimes en
fait voilà voilà ça
a vraiment un ces chiffons alors comment
vous avez tout découvert alors comment
j'ai tout découvert mais je l'ait quitté
au bout d'un mois et demi parce qu'en
fait elle essaie de me retourner contre
mon groupe d'amis parce qu'on est un
groupe on a une dizaine et essaie
également de retourner ce groupe d'amis
contre moi du coup je me suis dit
j'avais comme un instant comment dire
l'e10 est celle où c'est un an ça je me
suis dit c'est bizarre normalement quand
une relation est saine ne s'y passe pas
tout ça rien su donc
je commence à aller voir mon ami a
discuté avec elle effectivement en fait
cette fille-là doute yasmine aurait
tenté deux
prostituées faire prostituées 7,7 amis
en disant voilà mardi on va rencontrer
des des riches millionnaires etc moi
j'ai eu écoute ça je me suis dit mais ça
c'est un truc de ouf quoi genre je
m'explique il direct c'est impossible
donc voulu briguer qu'on voulait pas
dire qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire à me directement en fait je me
suis allé la voir je vais dire mais
qu'est ce qu'elle est et escorte en fait
je n'étais pas sur le monde si je dis
qu'est ce que t'es escorte pas dans tous
les cas moi je voulais je la quittais
moi quand je me suis engueulé avec elle
quand j'étais tout ça elle n'est même
pas en fait
regardez simplement est sûr c'est
qu'avec du recul maintenant puisque vous
a volé des choses où elle m'a volé
beaucoup de choses
alors je me suis rendu compte du coup le
soir où je l'équité ou vraiment a été
plus chez moi d'accord ma mère m'appelle
parce qu'elle rentrait de voyage à
bordeaux elle me dit ça c'est très
bizarre il ya un bague en émeraude dans
la salle de bains elle n'est pas censée
être là elle est normalement dans sa
boîte à bijoux il ya une photo de mon
défunt père qui était sur sa table de
chevet qui n'était pas du tout ça c est
là qu en plein de choses qui avait été
bougé dans la maison l'accord du coup
honnêtement moi j'ai pas du tout le lien
directement du doigt c'est très bizarre
et ouvre je loue mais il me rappelle 108
après 10 ans voit sa chalet bordant la
dans la boîte à bijoux il manque plein
de trucs donc l'alliance de mon père qui
est décédé il manquait pas plein de
bijoux pleins de jeux de famille les
voeux des vêtements que mon père de marc
est qui et qui est mort aussi de choix
des vêtements de ma mère pas un plein de
choses du coup même en moi directement
c'est ok on va porter plainte mais suite
à ça quand je porte plainte avec ma mère
cette yasmine nie les faits elle envoie
des photos compromettantes de moi à ma
mère en disant
en disant vous voudrez peut-être pas
voir ses photos de votre fille sur les
réseaux sociaux des trucs comme ça tu
vois quel prix les photos de photos
compromettantes en fête foraine à mort
foraine
mes photos compromettantes et moi on me
dit mais de vous seul ou là mais rien
d'illégal mais un défaut tenu coi mais
non elle photos nues
et anthian en compromettant ces pannes
une joie comportement qu'on n'aimerait
pas voir sur les réseaux sociaux
d'accord pas d'accord ah bon mais laval
numéro de faire la wii
est élu nous refait une
coaccusée
l'instant
alors
la sphère va plus loin puisque lll vous
dites que vous m'ont également sur ses
et messti qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire alors cette histoire de mai ses
cheveux honnêtement en fait bon
effectivement
j'ai détesté je peux pas prouver que
c'est elle qui nous a donné dans le sens
vous ai pas fait de tests avant noël
donc j'ai pas envie de l'attaqué
d'accord qui est d'accord travers le
rire au conditionnel mais d'accord
finalement sur instagram vous avez
décidé de révéler toute cette affaire et
dénoncer cette jeune femme voilà alors
la base pourquoi j'ai fait ça mais qu'en
fait elle nié les faits de m'avoir volée
moi j'étais sûr persuadé qu stèle elle
me disait c'est un peu bizarre parce que
hier soir tu as fait une soirée avec
tous tes amis et j'ai une vidéo d'eux
dans la chambre de sa mère donc la
police tu me
alors derrière vous avez reçu des
dizaines d'autres témoignages de
personnes qui se disent victimes de
yasmine également voilà ça dès que j'ai
mis l'histoire sur les réseaux sociaux
en fait j'ai reçu beaucoup beaucoup de
messages honnêtement je pense une
centaine de témoignages beaucoup de gens
qui avaient porté plainte depuis quatre
cinq ans un truc comme ça et là je me
suis dit ok c'est pas du tout un cas
isolé moi je pensais c'était juste
quelqu'un qui s'était tu m'avais
arnaquer quoi en fait pas du tout c'est
non non pas du tout c'était vraiment une
elle est connue pour sa part mme ans
mais personne n'a jamais arrêté il ya
beaucoup de plaintes contre elle depuis
longtemps et alors il sera avec nous
dans un instant pour donner sa version
c'est incroyable qu'elles soient avec
nous d'ailleurs ce soir vous avez
accepté de revoir yasmine lundi pourquoi
oui alors j'ai accepté de revoir yasmine
parce qu'en fait elle m'envoie des
messages pendant la nuit en disant
qu'elle avait piraté mon téléphone des
messages vous franchement me faisait
peur d'aggraver vu les échos que j'ai me
du coup et je pense ça a été ma plus
grosse erreur parce que certes je pense
que mon combat est sain après les
méthodes que j'utilise parfois sont un
peu douteuse c'est à dire que j'aurais
peut-être jamais dû aller la voir je
suis allée la voir je voulais m'assurer
que tous les témoignages que j'avais
était vrai ou pas je parce qu'en fait
elle me parlait d'un ordinateur où elle
pouvait faire tous ces délits des trucs
comme ça donc j'ai voulu faire le
clairement détective conan mais c'était
c'était rare c est
effectivement je suis allé la voir alors
elle n'a pas piraté mon téléphone j'ai
vu son cloud et effectivement il ya
énormément carte bleue dans son cloud et
voilà je les mets sur les routes ça vous
a volé beaucoup moins d'argent je
pourrais pas vous dire parce qu'en fait
les bijoux de famille et honnêtement
c'est quand et d'argent darcos à
l'argent fait elle m'a volé en liquide
c'est émilie millions dirhams un truc
comme ça qu'ils appartenaient du coup à
mon père qui n'a jamais changé oui jean
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle opérait
seul parce que parfois elle faisait des
déplacements un peu bizarre c'est ce que
vous avez à révéler et vous êtes aperçu
que c'était sans doute dans son travail
des scores qu'elle allait voir des
clients et ce qu'elles étaient aidés
pour ces escroqueries selon je pense pas
qu'elle soit aidée pour ces escroqueries
honnêtement je ne pense pas ou au pire
des cas si c'est le cas peut-être
qu'elle fait chanter des gens en disant
voilà aide moi pour ça sinon je révèle
satio mais je pense pas que ce soit une
organisation je pense que c'est juste le
cerveau de l'opération c'est là alors
non merci merci de son côté vous accuse
de diffamation et de la pousser au
suicide pourquoi bas les mâles m'attaque
pour diffamation incitation au suicide
incitation à la haine temps j'en sais
rien plein de chefs d'accusation moi je
suis pas très très bon endroit j'ai même
pas pris d'avocat mon but c'était
seulement de faire de la prévention est
que cette fille soit dénoncée après le
reste c'est le m'attaquer pour quoi que
ce soit